was there ever a time that you wanted to
turn back and go home yeah there were I
got offered to direct like to feature
films before a compound fracture and
they both fell through and I was just
like such a heartbreaking experience to
get it all the way to where they even
wrote me a check and I had a check in my
hand I went to the bank and it bounced
and then the person disappear happened
twice fact one time I actually was at
the bank with the person while it
bounced and I got so upset with this
person this was like maybe four or five
years ago I just let him have it I lost
it I like snapped everything that I had
had difficulties with at that point
culminated into this moment and I just
snapped on this guy I feel bad now but I
was like a 25 or 26 year old kid and I
made this 47 year old gentleman cry in
the bank I felt certain victory because
I actually told him what I'm he needed
to hear but at the same time I felt a
little bit bad about that because I had
reached a point where whatever it was
that was going on pushed me to the point
where I was doing that I felt like maybe
this business ain't for me I don't know
if I want to become a person that can do
this kind of thing I felt bad about it
for a while but I realized that I look
back on and I'm like man that guy really
screwed me though I spent so much time
and I have so many people favors to get
this guy's movie made and I was going to
direct it and it fell through and
everybody got screwed sucked I felt
really bad about it so what the guy did
kind of deserve it and as much as I feel
bad about that and I've kind of like
morally felt a little bit
you know regretful but I said something
things I said to that guy I learned from
that experience and I think I understood
that it's going to be hard if not
impossible to get what you want out of
this business unless you really have the
ability to push through those moments
when it's the hardest thing for you in a
world you feel like just crushed if you
can push past that I think you have what
it takes to stay in this industry I've
had friends that have fallen off and I
don't blame one bit I feel like I kind
of wish I did fall off at one point
because I've had to go through some
pretty intense experiences of my life as
a result of choosing this career path
but you know then you look at it like
well at least element yeah at least I'm
doing what I love and I can and I'm safe
you know I have a lot of friends that
are in the military and they have to do
things that threaten their life every
day but they still do it and if they got
if those guys can do it and they're in
their heart they're willing to put forth
that kind of effort you know what I have
my problems in my life for so minuscule
compared to that and I can't even
compare it and it's just like you know
you start to think about things like
that and you're like of course I'm going
to keep going why not did I mean it's
just like a
everybody like there's always somebody
else out there that's got a lot worse
than you do so just got to remember that
you